bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui ne fait pas que de
l'économie qui fait aussi de la science
fiction
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de prévisions prévisions pour
l'année
vont-elles arrivée ou non bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches consacré cette semaine à vos
prévisions olivier pour cette année à
2020 et pour passer en revue ces
fameuses prédictions nous sommes avec
jean marc daniel économiste et
professeur à escp europe bonjour jean
marc d'énergie bienvenues
elle est sans perdre de temps première
prédiction d'olivier une guerre avec
l'iran une guerre avec l'iran ces puces
c'est même plus une prédiction c'est la
prédiction c'était qu'est-ce qui se
passe s'il ya une guerre au moyen-orient
avec avec la lyre en mai ou avec un
autre pays et que à ce moment là ce a
provoqué ça pouvait provoquer un
désordre majeur qui pouvait enclencher
aussi une hausse extraordinaire du
pétrole qui pouvaient se retrouver à 200
$ sur une raffinerie complètement hs
on l'avait vu d'ailleurs l'année
dernière un peu avec l'arabie saoudite
au moment où il y avait ces
bombardements de l'iran sur certaines
puis
d'arabie saoudite et ou ponctuellement
le pétrole avait monté alors très vite
il était redescendu parce qu'il avait
absolument tout fait d'abord parce que
ça ne ça ne bloquait pas la production
pendant très longtemps et puis en plus
parce que les américains avaient dit
qu'ils allaient mettre sur le marché
leurs stocks stratégiques etc etc sera
donc on a fait faire baisser le pétrole
et il était il s'était rien passé mais
il faut quand même savoir que dans un
environnement qui est quand même assez
récessif ou en tout cas avec une
croissance qui est très très faible
partout dans les pays consommateurs si
vous avez tout d'un coup une très très
forte hausse du pétrole et qu'elle est
qu'elle reste sur des niveaux importants
ça va aggraver la crise fortement une
réaction en trois points le premier
point là où je rejoins olivier c'est le
fait qu'on est dans un environnement
récessif c'est à dire ou enfin de fort
ralentissement économique et donc des
hors jeu c'est quand même le prix du
pétrole c'est pas la même chose
à prix du pétrole qui montrait
rapidement moment où la croissance
s'effondre que au moment où on est
plutôt en phase de reprise
le deuxième élément est ce que c'est
vraisemblable alors là je suis pas sûre
ce soir si vraisemblable pour le
craignent parce que d'abord ce qui me
frappe c'est quand même le caractère un
peu modéré des réactions de téhéran est
surtout le fait que finalement je crois
qu'à terrail un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont pas mécontents de ce
qui est arrivé au général souleymane sy
c'est à dire que l'idée qu' un bloc ou
pouvoir à téhéran qui est un bloc uni
avec une vision de l'avenir très clair
et avec des intentions très très
précises est une idée à mon ami fausses
on est plutôt sur pouvoir finissant de
gens qui règlent là on est on est passé
de la phase enthousiaste à la phase cc
gorbatchev qui disait dans les
idéologies communistes alors on est un
peu dans ce cas il ya une phase sont les
naïfs qui pas le pouvoir
et puis ensuite ce sont les criminels et
ça finit par les courants et donc je
crois qu'à terrain on est passé à les
stades des corrompus et donc à partir de
ce moment là on peut gérer avec des
corrompus des criminels c'est difficile
les naïfs on peut jamais s'entendre avec
eux ils sont imprévisibles donc on est
plutôt et la toute dernière marque que
je ferai c'est que sur le marché du
pétrole effectivement ça pourrait aimer
le premier producteur mondial de pétrole
ce sont les états unis
le deuxième le canada donc on n'est plus
dans la situation où tout se jouer sur
le le proche et moyen-orient il ya en
revanche autour du pétrole juste après
la mort du général soliman le pétrole a
augmenté de 5% pour s'établir à 68
dollars le baril est ce que ça peut s
que dans une possible aggravation du
conflit ça pourrait encore oui ça
remonterait effectivement ça on pourrait
avoir des jours où ça monte à 200 mais
très rapidement les amériques
liquiderait et filippi augmenter leur
production
on est même dans des conditions on voit
pas ça mais certains jours sur le marché
dans le dakota ou au sud de l'alberta au
canada où il ya tellement de de pétrole
à évacuer que on l'a presque
gratuitement les gens vous disent prenez
le l'important c'est qu'on évacue
liaison la passion il ya tout de même
quelque chose sur le sur le pétrole
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
raffineries sont programmées sont montés
pour traiter des pétroles avec des pois
ça ça veut différent or ce qui est ce
qui aujourd'hui sort des champs de
pétrole américains n'est pas forcément
très table et donc que sert plutôt à
l'exportation mais ils sont quand même
obligé ils demeurent obligé d'importer
du pétrole plus léger ou plus lourd ça
dépends d'eads et de leur mix de
raffinage de pays comme le pétrole de la
mer du nord où le pétrole de darby ça ou
alors olivier on va passer à votre
deuxième prévision une guerre avec la
chine mais pas que commercial oui parce
que vous avez alors ça c'est sais c'est
pas souhaitable qu en jeu quand je fais
des scénarios je le souhaite pas
forcément donc et on verra dans la suite
que je sais pas forcément quelque chose
que je souhaite
non la chine
on a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui aujourd'hui essaient de lutter
contre l'hégémonie américaine et
il faut savoir que vous avez trois
marines en mer de chine qui circulent
dans un mouchoir de poche que c'est
toujours dangereux d'avoir trois marines
qui circulent dans un mouchoir de poche
parce que il peut toujours y avoir un
pépin on en a eu d'ailleurs l'année
dernière et l'année d'avant entre la
marine japonaise à marine américaine la
marine chinoise
les russes qui quelquefois envoie un
petit bateau là bas et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est dangereux et
d'autant que finalement ça et quand les
guerres se déclenchent elles se
déclenche toujours parce que les gens
ils y ont intérêt les états y ont
intérêt et donc on peut se poser la
question de savoir si quand les quand
les assiettes sont commence à être vide
on regarde dans l'assiette du voisin
donc que c'est un petit peu gênant et
aujourd'hui on sent quand même qu'il ya
des tensions internationales qui
augmente et se serait ce serait
épouvantable mais on n'est pas forcément
à l'abri de ce genre de plaisanterie
justement un pékin a
confirmé cette semaine que le premier
ministre chinois irait à washington
entre le 13 et le 15 janvier pour signer
un accord préliminaire pour mettre fin à
cette trêve dans cette guerre
commerciale
est ce que est ce que lui revenir en
détention n'ont pas oublié c'est
probable alors assez paradoxalement je
pense que la chine est plus dangereuse
que l'iran parce que d'abord la chine on
a une vision de la chine qui
effectivement export hors terre notre
bon sens or la chine va être en déficit
de sa balance des paiements courants en
cette année l'été juste à l'équilibré
l'année dernière il ya dix ans à le
dégager 10 % d'excédent voyez les
chinois partout oui commence à parler le
début de l'appel la route de la soie
with salé berry mais est là maintenant
la chine commence à voir des problèmes
de financement d'ailleurs liquide une
partie de sa dette publique américaine
est ce qu est la forme pour payer
effectivement ses importations elles
n'arrivent pas à se sortir de la
situation rend kong tout ça dure depuis
six mois il va y avoir des élections à
taïwan est donc là clairement elle
soutient sous main le culot minh tang
l'ancien parti de tchang kaï chek pour
qu'ils en arrivent là il faut quand même
c'est quand même les ennemis story des
communistes chinois parce que le parti
indépendantiste a le vent en poupe et
donc pour et puis si un missile qui part
de pyongyang et qui tombe
du côté de séoul et tokyo
il faudra bien que quelque part et il
assuma il assure effectivement une phase
de suivi donc je pense qu'on a un pays
qui est aux abois pays qui connaît des
difficultés économiques un pays qui n'a
plus effectivement les perspectives
qu'ils avaient et la guerre devient à ce
moment là une violation la chine dans
vos prévisions
c'est la chute des banques chinoises qui
accélère accélérait la dédollarisation
personne n'en parle mais vous avez quand
même de temps en temps une banque qui
qui saute alors évidemment c'est à faut
bien comprendre que c'est pas c'est pas
l'europe ou les états unis donc vous en
entendez parler et puis après vous en
entendrez plus parler juste après parce
que l'état règle le problème se dirait
il n'empêche que ça ne devrait pas
accélérer les choses au niveau des
dollarisation set j'avais fait un
scénario il ya il ya deux ans où je
disais attention ils sont en train de
faire des stocks d'or avec les russes et
il augmente très fortement leur stock
d'or et pourquoi pas créer une monnaie
qui serait concurrentes au dollar et ce
dès de l'arize et 11 ans une monnaie qui
serait le yuan le nouveau johan si vous
voulez qu'ils seraient dépendants de 2,2
d'un stock d'or et convertissent à blanc
nord bon ils l'ont fait mais pour
certains contrats pétrole contre yohan
converti sable en or mais parler de
quelque chose qui serait plus étendue là
il est évident que s'ils ont des
problèmes comme ceux comme cela avec des
banques qui se casse la figure les unes
après les autres ils pourraient être
tentés de vendre quelques trésors is
américaine de plus en plus rapidement
et alors ougney ça changera pas grand
chose puisque toute façon vous aurez la
fête qui va se mettre en face et qui va
joyeusement acheter tout ce qui se
présentera donc que ça n'entraînera pas
une forte hausse des taux aux etats unis
comme certains pouvaient là peuvent
l'attendre mais en revanche ça va quand
même changer un certain nombre de choses
et l'hégémonie du dollar risque de
prendre des coups or ça les américains
ils n'aiment pas donc une des
dollarisation la chine paraît possible
ça me paraît plus délicat est plus
difficile à envisager ça c'est peut-être
un espoir mais c'est pas forcément un
espoir secret que je partage
si on pouvait remettre en place l'état
leur offre en tout cas une bonne équipe
on est international et dans la monnaie
d'un pays qui en profitent pour
rançonner les autres ce serait pas mal
au revoir ce que je pense sur la chine
en tant que tel c'est que le système
bancaire est effectivement dans une
situation délicate donc la banque
centrale a commencé à baisser les
réserves obligatoires et tout ça et donc
elle est en train d'essayer de laisser
filer l'inflation dans un contexte où il
ya des prix qui montent
c'était en particulier on le prix de la
viande porcine qui quand même des enjeux
pour la population très concret qu'il y
ait au fait que l'épidémie une épizootie
très très lourdes sur le port en chine
et l'occident aller de l'inflation et si
en plus cette inflation avec ce centre
sur quelques produits traités on en
revient au point précédent
c'est à dire que le gouvernement chinois
il est pas il est dans une situation
assez délicate par rapport à ça les
américains je crois que sur le dollar
ils sont assez serein moreau ils auront
alors ils peuvent se permettre par
exemple alan greenspan qu'on ressort de
temps en temps donc sans dernier
obsession c'est le retour à l'étalon or
il ya ceux qui disent ils est gâteux ya
ceux qui disent il l'a toujours été
ce n'est pas tout vu la politique
monétaire qu'il advenait je suis pas
loin de penser que c'est vrai et puis il
ya ceux qui disent mais après tout
finalement mettre un peu de discipline y
compris chez nous ce serait pas mal donc
je crois que derrière la dédollarisation
qui ne paraît pas d'actualité il ya
quand même le sentiment quelque part que
ce système peut pas être éternelle que
le dos la privilège qui peut pas être
acceptée éternellement dans l'économie
mondiale non mais si on va marquer une
courte pause on revient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire les prévisions
d'olivier de la marche pour l'année 2020
et on en parle avec jean marc daniel
économiste et professeur à escp europe
alors olivier vous n'êtes pas le seul à
avoir fait à des prévisions pour cette
année 2020 on regarde celle d'antoine
vassal c'est l'heure du tiroir caisse
pas de raison qu'ils n'aient qu'olivier
de la marche qu'ils fassent des
prévisions nous aussi aux tiroirs cash
on va jouer les madame irma oui je vois
votre avenir
alors à quoi s'attendre en 2020 on ne va
pas vous faire trop de prévisions
seulement trois ponts 3 prévisions
fastoche d'abord le breakbeat va avoir
lieu promis cette fois c'est réglé boris
johnson a eu sa majorité en décembre
le parti travailliste a pris une fessée
et avec les conservateurs au pouvoir
plus rien n'empêche le royaume et non de
clore cette interminable histoire
enfin reste encore à négocier l'accord
avec l'ue veut un bel accord pour que
tout le monde soit content ensuite selon
nous la réforme des retraites va
probablement passer
bon on sait pas trop à quoi elle
ressemblera au final et ouais le
gouvernement fait peu à peu des
concessions pour diverses professions
pompiers prof danseurs de l'opéra de
paris et autres bref la réforme revoit
peu à peu ses objectifs à la baisse
d'ici à mi février lorsqu'elle sera
étudié à l'assemblée le gouvernement a
encore le temps de faire des concessions
et l'âge pivot par exemple enfin on va
se permettre une dernière prévision un
peu différente
et si olivier delamarche changé d'idée
et croyait un peu à l'union européenne à
l'euro à emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement pourquoi pas toi non faut
pas rêver non plus on voit peut-être pas
si clair que ça dans notre boule de
cristal bonnes années 2020 avec encore
plus de tiroirs cash
ouah
dans l'année 2020 appartient martin
balayer une réaction on va sur le alors
c'est pas vraiment des prévisions je
vous dis tout de suite la troisième vous
oublier
sur le sur le break site c'est une
maintenant c'est une certitude
on sait qu'ils vont sortir toute la
question est de savoir comment ils
sortent ce qu'ils sortent façon brutale
ou pas je pense que ça sera plus
désagréable pour l'union qui sera le 31
janvier donc plus désagréable pour
l'union européenne que pour le royaume
uni c'est à dire que il faut savoir que
si ils s'en vont ce qui est le cas qui
va payer
qui va payer ce qu'il payait avant dans
le budget européen m'a forcément les
allemands les français et et que ça
pourrait quand même bien donner des
idées à beaucoup de se dire que
finalement on est mieux seul que mal
accompagné
ce qui risque d'être le cas avec le
royaume uni est donc donné des idées à
certains de sortir non seulement de
l'union européenne mais aussi de sortir
de l'euro c'est d'ailleurs votre
quatrième prévisions le break cité un
éclatement de la zone euro jean marc
daniel non moi je crois pas du tout à un
éclatement de la zone euro et j'attends
même avec une certaine impatience
l'entrée de l'ecosse dans la zone euro
je pense que nous allons inexorablement
vers l'entrée de l'ecosse dans la zone
rouge je pense que malgré son âge à la
vitesse à laquelle vont les choses la
reine elizabeth ii sera obligé d'avoir
un passeport pour les à balmoral qui est
sa résidence d'été était en écosse et je
pense que le gouvernement les causes
devenue indépendante se fera un plaisir
de lui réclamer ses papiers au passage
du mur d'hadrien
quant à la date du bois exceed ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est qu'il ya débat
d'angleterre sur le fait de savoir si on
le prend le 31 janvier
ou le 30 janvier parce que le 30 janvier
c'est l'anniversaire de l'exécution de
chars le premier et donc il ya un
certain nombre d'anglais qui disent on
s'est libéré d'une monarchie qui étaient
influencés par les français et on va se
libérer d'une autre structure
toujours aussi mal influencé par les
français les langues
voilà pour l'anecdote alors olivier pour
vous c'est un pays de l'est alors ça
peut être aussi ça on en parle
vous avez quand même beaucoup de pays de
l'est ce qui sont manifesté plusieurs
fois alors sur des sujets qui en général
touché l'immigration et donc à l'entrée
massive d'immigrés en europe et qui ne
veulent pas chez eux et donc on peut se
poser la question avec une montée quand
même des partis qui sont europhobe pour
pas dire autre chose et qu'ils
souhaitent
probablement sortir donc c'est une
possibilité
je dis pas que c'est ça qui va arriver
mais c'est vrai vous avez vous avez la
pologne où ça fait ça et autres pays qui
sont il l'est qui la hongrie qui rue
dans les brancards et qu'ils
s'aperçoivent que l'europe n'est pas
enfin en tout cas bruxelles n'est pas ce
qu'il souhaite
alors je ne sais pas si les causes va
rétablir la frontière est embêté la
reine d'angleterre mais en revanche ce
que je pense c'est que l'union
européenne va avoir quelques soucis en
2020 ça vous paraît probable que la
pologne ou la hongrie sorte c'est là un
des différends historiques que j'ai avec
olivier c'est dans seulement je pense
que ce n'est pas probable mais je pense
que ce n'est pas souhaitable
alors après possible c'est possible mais
je pense que ce n'est pas probable juste
deux éléments pour ça les plus
eurosceptiques quand on regarde la liste
les pays d'europe de l'est ça reste
quand même les tchèques
andrei babis et l'actuel premier
ministre constituer une majorité avec le
parti communiste les restes du parti
communiste tchèque qui est encore assez
influent en république tchèque et sur le
programme la seule chose qu'ont exigé
les communistes s'étaient qu'il négocie
avec bruxelles l'aménagement et jusqu'à
présent les communistes continuent à les
soutenir alors qu'il ne fait rien et
qu'au contraire vis-à-vis des
britanniques il a été relativement
exigeant et assez européen donc je pense
que finalement cette idée de sortir et
le deuxième élément c'est que le fmi va
fermer à la fin du mois son antenne à
athènes qui avait été mise en place dans
le cadre de la restructuration dans
l'économie grecque
autour de la crise de la zone euro et
donc le fait bien 10
derrière nous ah oui donc la crise de
l'euro est derrière nous tant que les
faits mais je sais que pour olivier si
ça devait faire vibrer donc non enfin on
peut pas sérieusement dire que la crise
grecque est finie les grecs sont dans un
état pitoyable on n'a absolument pas
réduit la dette grecque
on continue à payer pour qu'ils puissent
nous rembourser le le mois précédent en
face et grotesque de dire que les grecs
s'en sont sortis grâce à à l'europe et
grâce aux fmiste une plaisanterie donc
madame lagarde
retournez vous vous la verrez la crise
grecque juste à l'ailé mort mais ont
failli tout une émission sur la grèce et
tout ça les taux d'intérêt sur la dette
à dix ans grecs sont désormais
inférieurs à ceux de l'italie états unis
mais évidemment puisque tout le monde
sait que l'europe continuera avec madame
lagarde qui a suivi monsieur draghi
continuera à mettre des sous sur la
table donc de toute façon vous êtes une
banque vous avez l'occasion d'avoir une
dette qui est garantie par la bce
pourquoi voulez vous ne pas en profiter
sauf que certains l'avait fait la veille
de du haircut de 75% ça leur a coûté un
peu cher l'histoire et les envoie sur
7/7 prévisions olivier le big one le
réveil de la faille de san andres oui
alors ne s'était c'était juste pour
apporter un petit
un petit une prévision un peu hors
économique mais je suis tombé sur un
article qui disait ça m'a un peu effaré
sur un article qui disait que la
probabilité du big one était montée à 75
% ce que je trouve quand même un peu
effrayant
et donc alors d'autres d'autres sources
disent pour 2010 2030 buzz qui est
demain ses dents dans une dizaine
d'années douzaine d'années
ben big one ça veut dire vous faites une
croix sur la californie ce qui peut
quand même peser lourd dans l'économie
américaine
voyez alors de deux choses par rapport à
ça d'abord il y ait des gens qui me
rassure en tant qu'économiste c'est les
métérologues pour tout le temps et les
géologues
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait un
géologue prévoir le tremblement de terre
d'hier justice italien d'un jour à
l'occasion d'un tremblement terre a
condamné des géologues en leur disant il
ya un an après ce non assistance à
personne en danger puisque vous saviez
qu'il y voit le tremblement terre et
vous avais prévenu personne alors ils
ont dit pas dû on ne pouvait pas le
prévoir
ah ben on attend la justice ali nahdi
détournement de fonds publics
c'est à dire vous êtes payés et vous ne
servez à rien boxe et du détournement de
fonds publics et donc je pense que les
géologues effectivement mais en tant
qu'économiste finalement la deuxième
remarque jeffrey c'est quand même que la
californie c'est équivalent du pit de la
france est l'équivalent du pipe de
l'inde
donc vous regardez les proportions qui
peut y avoir bon mais c'est quand même
c'est l'équivalent sur le poids
économique de l'inde ou de la france qui
disparaîtraient donc ce serait pas
anodin département du drap bull même
mais si on revient rapidement en france
avec cette huitième prévisions l'arrivée
à l'elysée de ségolène royal où marion
maréchal-le pen à la présidentielle est
prévu qu'en 2022 1 mais ce que ces
personnels ces personnalités dans le
forez émergent
un peu plus entre 2020 et on a vu m'a
même ségolène royal
qui un nous a beaucoup amusé il ya
quelques semaines on nous expliquant qu'
elle faisait de le grand écart entre les
deux pôles on sait très bien ce qu'elle
fait on sait qu'elle a ruiné le poitou
charentes et donc que comme ma prévision
2019 était que son mari revenait aux
commandes
il n'est pas revenu je me suis dit
peut-être que son ex femme à son
ex-femme où il son ex-mari son ex femme
allait revenir aux commandes aux plus
hauts postes
bah écoutez ça serait juste une
catastrophe mais enfin bon on va pas en
parler non plus des lustres et d'élus je
pense que jean marc et maintenant on
serais tu moi j'appartiens à une
génération de voir deux choses aussi
monstrueuse on mettait un carré blanc ok
il en femme regarde pas ça je préviens
une vision horrifié ses notes reconnaît
comme olivier lemay alors que l'élection
présidentielle est en 2002 je ne sais
pas si c'est une forme d'impatience il
l'attend je me dis c'est qu'il faut
peut-être peut-être monsieur macron
party à l'elysée
poursuivi par des gilet jaune et que
ségolène royal prendrait sa place
enfin on peut on peut imaginer des
scénarios du pire puisque le pire a
quand même tendance à arriver assez
fréquemment
allez on va terminer sur une note
positive puisque selon vos olivier un
inventeur pourrait trouver une source
illimité gratuite et non pour le monde
d'énergie
ben le pauvre se ferait flinguer tout de
suite et s'y trouvait ça malheureusement
je pense que certains lobbys pétroliers
et aux autres lui ferait pas celle envie
de le mettre sur le marché
oui oui elle a aussi des remarques la
première les lobbys sont puis ça regarde
pas sa part ali quand même il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent vous savez
c'est le charbon était à l'origine des
incendies tout ça est le premier indice
id ou êtes vous sûr parce qu'il ya
encore c'est quand même un exportateur
net de charbon l'australie et donc même
sur le charbon les gens sont capables
d'avoir une influence sur les politiques
toutes dernières remarques
au xviiie siècle les grands économistes
étaient des physiocrates et il dit voilà
on sait utiliser le soleil de demain
c'est l'agriculture c'est le soleil qui
va arriver qui va faire augmenter la
production agricole et ça on sait
utiliser le soleil d'hier parce que le
charbon justement c'était le soleil il
faut utiliser le soleil d'aujourd'hui
parce que c'est une source de infinie et
alors ils avaient écrit à d'alembert qui
était le savant préférence du xviiie
siècle et qui leur avait dit
rassurez-vous avant la fin du xviiie
siècle
nous serons capables d'utiliser le
soleil d'aujourd'hui on est en 2000 vers
d'utiliser toujours par le soleil et
d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est un espoir mais je pense pas
que ça puisse être considérée comme une
prévision merci à merci beaucoup à jean
marie danielle d'avoir été parmi nous je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
professeur à l'ocp europe c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité pour retrouver d'anciens
numéros
rendez vous sur notre site internet à
l'adresse rt france point est tv olivier
votre dernier mot prions pour qu'aucune
de ces prévisions ne se déroule en 2020